are of phone number is two one nine to David
p.
Take a listen to this voicemail that I received.
Very interesting take on, uh, the entire theme
song stuff that we've been talking about.
Take a listen to this
David.
David, I was just watching your youtube videos.
Did I miss something?
Was there a song contest and I missed on it?
I hope it's not too late to enter, but like
what do you think about this one?
Okay.
I've been working on it for the last like
whole three minutes.
Okay.
David, pack me on his June.
Bring in.
You done.
You.
Oh, Ooh, Ooh, Ooh.
I think that's
[inaudible].
And you let go like, no.
Who else?
He's actual role.
I'm a big fan of you.
I'm glad you keep it honest and if you want
that like it's all yours.
Oh, free.
You don't even gotta put my name on it.
Yeah, I'm actually a little bit worried about
this is it?
Why does it, why does it need to be qualified?
Whether a Jewish person is honest?
That's a little weird, but in any case, we're
keeping the theme song we have.
We are not accepting new submissions at this
time.
I do appreciate it to the extent that this
was genuine.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Sign up@joinpacman.com or at patrion.com/david
Pakman show both.
We'll give you instant access to the bonus.
Jo, many important stories to be discussed
there today.
The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.